Democratic congressman john conyers is
the first lawmaker to quit over sexual
misconduct allegations he resigned
yesterday but still denies any
wrongdoing a six woman has publicly come
forward to accuse him of harassment
Conyers called into a local Detroit
radio station to announce his departure
I am retiring today and I want everyone
to know how much I appreciate the
support my legacy can't be compromised
or diminished in any way by what we're
going through this too shall pass
Adriana Diaz is in Detroit and the
district that Conyers represented for
nearly fifty three years Adriana good
morning good morning the former
congressman endorsed his son John
Conyers the third to replace him and
with that may have started a family feud
that's because his grandnephew also
plans to run for the seat the twenty
seven term congressman's decision to
retire came days after leaders on both
sides of the aisle called for his
resignation including House Minority
Leader Nancy Pelosi and Speaker Paul
Ryan but support for the longest-serving
african-american in history runs deep in
his district his supporters say Conyers
is being unfairly held to a different
standard than other congressmen who have
faced similar allegations we spoke to
Deanna Maher who has accused the former
ranking member of the Judiciary
Committee of multiple unwanted sexual
advances she says the retirement means
little I say he's an icon of corruption
the system will go on with or without
congressman Conyers
Maher says Conyers represents a larger
problem of accountability in Congress
and that if politicians like him are
protected the culture won't change
bianna adrianna thank you